The joe rogan experience.
One of the things,
yeah,
about being,
um,
a comic in Boston is that,
uh,
there was a lot of craft too.
I mean you,
you came along,
it's a little bit after me about after uh,
my generation of open makers.
Uh,
but there was a,
there was a lot of emphasis put on the
craft of like the use of the word fuck.
Like you know,
you could use the word fuck,
but don't over fuck.
Don't break the fuck meter.
That's what you guys would say.
I remember that.
I try to keep it to three,
three to five fucks.
Yeah.
Like Donovan used to say it.
Donovan was a genius man.
Donovan Donovan is one of those,
the g
one of my favorite lines ever is,
he's talking about uh,
being at work and your boss breaking
your balls about going on break.
And one of my favorite,
like most one of those blue collar details
that I never heard anybody bring up
on stage.
He was imitating given shit to his boss.
He said,
I'll take a 20 minute shit
on the clock if I want.
And I was just like,
oh my God.
I used to work with a guy who did
that everyday just dogging it.
Just hated his life.
He would grab the newspaper.
It was just like he got,
we just had a break.
The Roach coach pulled up.
We just had the break
and he used it to get,
he was so fucking miserable to get
from the break to get to lunch.
He had this routine where
he would go and he's like,
I have to go to the bathroom and
we would all break his balls.
It's like,
Joe,
you get,
you fucking went in that like nine hours,
you know?
And he would just laugh
and he would just walk in,
sit down and just read the newspaper.
I don't think he was taking his shit.
He would just sit on this
bowl just to have this like,
I never forget that shit.
Like how lucky my life was to tell jokes.
Let's just say that like your game plan
is you ain't your job so bad that you
pretend to take a shit but 20 minutes
every day just to get to lunch.
It's a lot of guys that
can get fired for that.
Oh,
now a days with all the
cameras and everything.
They can literally break down exactly
when you cause back in the day that fuck
he was six minutes.
Yeah,
they wouldn't let me have a hernia.
How quick am I supposed to take a shit?
They bring it to a diet counselor,
tried to get you.
We have to figure out,
figure out some sort of a way to optimize
your time better here at performance
inc.
Setting
the people in the cubicles
that you're walking by.
As you go to the,
uh,
as you go to the toilet there,
they're pulling your load
while you're shifting.
That was one of the dumbest things.
We have a dead.
We used to,
we used to ship out like
this computer software.
We are the middleman between like
software companies and people ordering
software.
This is like the 80,
so there's no internet.
So people would come to our company,
I mean the company I worked for where
they had all this software at Lotus one,
two,
three,
Dbas,
all this old school shit.
And,
uh,
one day we got into this stupid guy,
competitive thing like fucking morons.
We didn't realize it like who
was shipping out the most.
So we started saving them,
competing with one another and uh,
this guy shipped out a hundred packages.
So the next day I did one 20,
and then he did one 60 move fighting
and then the fucking management got room
for it.
They're like,
oh yeah,
why don't you start keeping a,
an uh,
a number.
And then they figured out who is being
the most and guys started losing their
jobs.
So I even back then I was like,
dude,
stop fucking doing it.
Stop doing it because we're,
we're literally cutting our own fucking,
well,
you're making yourself put
yourself in a race that's,
there's no way.
We didn't know any better.
Yeah,
we didn't know any better idiots.
We like 1920 that we,
we used to fucking go out and drink like
a 12 pack of beer and eat McDonald's at
one in the morning.
And by like eight o'clock
we were unloading trucks,
fine,
laughing and then we would work.
We do all this shit.
And then during lunch hour we would go
out and play basketball and like just
regular sneakers and like five o one
blues member that the black and fly and
you'd be that.
You'd come back and pouring
sweat and then just keep,
unless it's the greatest
shape I was ever in my life.
And then in the end of work I would
then go lift and go ride a bike,
do them at one time I
want a bike ride hammered.
I was so into working
out fucking bike ride.
I'm on like a 12 speed bike that
I bought when I still have it,
by the way,
am I garage,
I refuse to throw shit out and a,
I remember being hammered on the bike
and I'm sweating so I'm becoming more
hammered.
I was going to do this 11 mile loop.
Then it became oh seven and then I just
kind of came back and I was like on the
bike laughing and I was like 2021 and
was only beginning to understand the
fragility of life.
And I knew that what I
was doing was stupid,
but I couldn't get,
I,
I just kept picturing my friends laughing
at me and I was literally by myself
riding this bike,
laughing drunk,
driving up the street.
And I'm in here for two and a half hours.
Like I'm just taking snippets
from fucking the eighties I got,
I got nothing left
used to be able to bounce back.
So,
well,
when you're young,
it's amazing.
When you're 20 years old,
you'd get hammered the next day.
You barely feel anything.
Dude,
Donald's and tear down that place.
I would get to quarter
pounders with cheese,
a large fry,
a six piece mcnugget
and I never liked him.
I never liked him.
I never thought it an ice
to try the different sauces.
I used to go with the mustard,
never tastes good.
I just wanted something to fill the void.
And then I would get like a
couple of cheeseburgers and uh,
I think it just a giant coke and just
throw that down and wake up the next day
with a flat stomach.
And I had already drank like,
you know,
eight,
nine beers.
We've got to fight.
We got into a fight one time right under
the Golden Arches and the next town
over.
I don't know what happened.
These guys came in drunk,
classic Boston shift.
They just come walking in and
they give everybody the finger.
Of course we respond to it and next
thing you know we're out underneath the
golden arches.
There's like five of us and two of them.
And uh,
my buddy,
we always fought,
he starts swinging on the big
one and then the little one,
he sort of jumped in and just became
this big and it looked like wrestling,
you know,
when like they all come running out of
the dressing to help each other on snow.
Everybody's drunk just fallen down.
We so fucking drunk.
The cops were there like sort
of misting mace for like,
and I don't know how long,
like we didn't even see him pull up.
There's this that I like
being in the flight.
Then all of a sudden everybody's like,
eyes are like up and shit.
And then what was hilarious was they
just broke us up and they fuck it.
And then like two seconds later we're
back in our car and the same two guys we
were fighting come and back up to the car.
It's like,
where does the cops go?
I thought it was over.
And the guys like that
was a bullshit pajamas.
I the little one goes,
I still remember,
he goes,
we laugh at you a shit.
It was fucking nuts.
I got to give it up to him.
And it was,
it was,
you know,
fucking four on two or whatever.
And uh,
they didn't give a shit.
They laughed.
They definitely laughed at our shit.
They,
they didn't care.
They hate that Mason.
They came right back.
They were ready right up to our faced,
right up to our Ford escort.
They did not give a fuck if
you're still in into the fighting,
you just got maced.
That's what he needed.
Something happened cause I don't,
nobody got it full on.
Like it was just like you're,
I thought we thought it was the snow.
Like they had thrown a rock salt
cause we were on the ground.
I don't,
I don't know what it was,
but it was just like
unbelievably fucking Arab.
But we were hammered,
I sounds like a fucking police
car pulled up and nobody noticed.
That's hilarious.
Like,
Hey,
you gotta got to whatever was going on.
Okay.